president biden's new effort to pressure
businesses to get their employees
vaccinated and the pushback already from
many states mr biden says a forthcoming
emergency rule from the labor department
requiring coveted shots or weekly
testing will apply to 100 million
americans about two-thirds of the u.s
workforce republican governors are
lining up to stop it however ed o'keefe
is at the white house for us ed good
morning to you so we've got politics and
public health colliding once again when
will this rule go into effect that is a
very good question tony we still don't
quite know when that labor department
rules coming but that isn't stopping the
president from urging private companies
to do what the federal government's done
by implementing mandates for vaccines
for workers he used to stop at a chicago
area construction company on thursday to
call on workers to help close the book
on the pandemic
we have the tools
we're using them we're making progress
we just have to finish
the job
finish the job
the biden administration is preparing
new workplace rules that will require
companies with more than 100 employees
to have vaccine or testing mandates but
as with most everything these days there
is a political element to this at least
24 republican-controlled states are
preparing for legal challenges to that
mandate even before the labor department
finishes writing it
as for the push to get more children
vaccinated pfizer and beyond tech have
applied for emergency authorization use
of their shot in kids ages 5 to 11. an
fda advisory panel is expected to review
all the data by the end of this month
meaning it could be that kids of a
certain age end up in school with a shot
in the arm by later this fall gail
thank you very much ed